[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui la serbie et le
kosovo le conflit n'est pas encore tout
à fait et entre ces deux voisins
balkaniques et menace aujourd'hui de se
rallumer et cela malgré les efforts de
médiation de bruxelles et de washington
qui essayent tant bien que mal de faire
avancer le processus de normalisation
politique où en est-on actuellement dans
ce bras de fer entre belgrade et
pristina le 20 septembre le gouvernement
kosovar interdit la circulation des
véhicules ayant des plaques
d'immatriculation serbe en riposte des
centaines de serbes locaux bloquent
plusieurs routes menant à des postes
frontières la serbie dénonce une
violation des accords précédemment
conclus et menacent de lourdes
conséquences cette montée de tension
arrive au moment où de la stagnation du
dialogue bilatéral
aucune avancée tangible après deux
rencontres au plus haut niveau cet été
sous l'égide de bruxelles alors que le
kosovo exige de belgrade la
reconnaissance de son indépendance la
serbie entend promouvoir l'idée de la
création d'un organe de pouvoir local
représentant la minorité serbe au kosovo
côté diplomatique les deux cherche du
soutien dans des camps différentes
soutenue par les etats-unis et l'union
européenne le kosovo ne cesse de
développer ses liens internationaux en
vue d'obtenir la reconnaissance
internationale la serbie elle compte sur
l'appui de la russie et de la chine pour
barrer la route de pristina vers
l'adhésion à des organisations
internationales
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il faut
savoir sur ces deux voisins antagonistes
des balkans c'est le blitz autrefois
venu au sein d'un même état serbe
belgrade et pristina à vivre de fait
séparément depuis le conflit au kosovo
de la fin des années 90 en 2008
christina officialise le divorce en
proclamant son indépendance
la serbie continue néanmoins de
considérer le kosovo comme une partie
intégrante de son territoire alors qu'à
peu près la moitié des membres de l'onu
le reconnaît comme un état souverain en
termes de superficie
la serbie est presque deux fois plus
grande que son voisin et les occupent
près de 87 milles 130 kilomètres carrés
contre onze mille kilomètres carrés pour
le kosovo quant à la population là aussi
la serbie a un avantage de taille
presque 7 millions de personnes contre
un million sept cent soixante quinze
mille pour pristina pareil pour le
domaine économique la serbie a un pib
par habitant presque deux fois plus
grand que celui du kosovo au pays le
plus pauvre de la région du point de vue
politique les deux états sont dotés d'un
régime parlementaire en serbie les
fonctions du chef de l'état sont
exécutés par le président aleksandar
vucic alors qu'au kosovo c'est le
premier ministre albine courtier qui
dirige le pays
plus de vingt ans après la fin de la
guerre du kosovo la tension reste
palpable entre belgrade et pristina
en réponse à l'interdiction des plaques
serbe belgrade menace de conséquences et
évoque un retrait possible des
négociations de normalisation d'ailleurs
le dialogue serbo kosovare connaît très
peu d'avancé ces derniers temps personne
ne veut faire des concessions la serbie
refuse d'envisager la reconnaissance du
kosovo alors que pristina sap la
création de l'association des
municipalités serbes un organe de
pouvoir local représentant la minorité
serbe les accusations mutuelles de
crimes de guerre et la question
religieuse éloigne encore plus les
perspectives de normalisation politique
est temps que le dialogue patine avec la
serbie le kosovo cherche la
reconnaissance auprès d'autres membres
de la communauté internationale ces
efforts sont soutenus par washington et
bruxelles quel incident belgrade à
reconnaître le kosovo la diplomatie
serbe elle redouble d'efforts pour
priver le kosovo des reconnaissances
existantes et surtout pour l'empêcher de
rejoindre les organisations
internationales alors en quoi la récente
escalade entre la serbie et le kosovo
risque-t-elle d'affecter la stabilité
internationale pourquoi après une
dizaine d'années de pourparlers le
règlement politique n'est toujours pas
au rendez vous
quelle est l'origine du conflit entre
belgrade et pristina pour répondre à
toutes ces questions nous rejoignons
tout de suite alexis trou d'un
professeur de géopolitique à
l'université de melin directeur de
l'institut europe orientale monsieur
trout bonjour bonjour à vous et metz
merci de m'avoir accueilli tout d'abord
comment va évoluer selon vous la récente
escalade entre la serbie et le kosovo à
quelles réponses faut-il s'attendre de
la part de la serbie alors il est vrai
que la semaine dernière il ya eu en
plein coeur de l'europe une tension très
forte parce que d'un côté la police du
kosovo a envoyé des chars
dans le nord du kosovo ce à quoi
les mines ont été laminés serbe a
répondu en érigeant des barricades et
donc on a eu peur qu'il y ait un conflit
à nouveau aussi fort d'ailleurs que dans
les années 90 fort heureusement le 1er
octobre vendredi 1er octobre il ya eu un
accord
diplomatique entre le présent gucci tx
et sous l'égide de l'union européenne
qui marque une nette victoire de la
diplomatie goodrich puisque grâce à cet
accord d'un côté il n'y a plus de
barricades mais en échange de de la
suppression ces barricades la police du
kosovo a
accepté de quitter les territoires du
nord font pourquoi mais parce que depuis
2013 il faut absolument dire que
et ce qui devait se faire
les serbes avaient accepté une autonomie
une quasi indépendance du kosovo mais en
échange d'une autonomie du kosovo nord
là où habitent principalement et sel
lorsque des pouvoirs albanais n'ont
jamais accepté donc dans cette
perspective là l'accord de vendredi
dernier et fort positif parce que il
permet d'éviter une escalade
vraiment de la violence et en même temps
il replace vucic dangereux international
et mais le dirigeant albanais albine
courtilles finalement en porte à faux on
voit bien il n'a pas dans cette histoire
n'a pas été soutenu par les états unis
alors maintenant presque quinze ans
après l'indépendance du kosovo elle est
plutôt vu comme un échec ont un succès
selon vous alors 15 ans après force est
de constater qu'on est dans un échec
total de
l'état hôte au profane du qu'aux échecs
d'abord puisque c'est un état qui était
bâti qui avait été bâti sur l'idée
onusienne de
nation building c'était l'idée très
généreuse à l'époque l'idée que à partir
d'un terreau qui n'existaient pas se
taire que le qu'aux historiquement n'a
jamais existé et bien créé un état qui
réunirait
plusieurs nations la nation albanaise la
nation serbe la nation
[Musique]
rome or force est de constater que
chacune de ces nations se tourner vers
sa matrice les albanais beaucoup de
leurs dirigeants veulent une union avec
l'albanie voisine les serbes vivent
grâce à sous perfusion grâce à
une
salaire payée par belgrade et les roms
ou les turcs et bien regarde vers
là aussi leur
leur pays
mr c'est-à-dire l'inde pour les roms et
puis la turquie prélature le cosmos et
aussi si vous voulez un état qui a
failli puisque c'était ce qu'on appelle
un failed state annette a failli c'est
en effet l'état en europe qui est touché
par le taux de chômage le plus élevé en
europe
c'est l'état où
[Musique]
règnent des trafics en tous genres donc
trafic de drogue trafic d'armes
trafic de femmes aussi mais la
prostitution et donc si vous voulez
c'est un échec total de cet état du
kosovo quinze ans après
monsieur trou de merci beaucoup nous
allons poursuivre notre analyse tout de
suite mais nous vous retrouverons à la
fin de cette émission pour plus de
détails sur ce thème merci encore un
sujet historiquement épineux les plaques
d'immatriculation sont au coeur de la
nouvelle montée de tension entre la
serbie et le kosovo le 20 septembre le
gouvernement kosovar interdit les
plaques d'immatriculation serbe sur son
territoire désormais tout voiture serbe
qui entrent sur le territoire du kosovo
doit à la frontière acheté pour 5 euros
des plaques d'immatriculation provisoire
kosovar et démonter les plaques
d'immatriculation d'origine les voitures
avec les anciennes immatriculations
d'avant l'indépendance ne seront pas non
plus autorisé à circuler afin de mettre
en oeuvre cette décision les forces
spéciales kosovars lourdement armées
sont déployées dans les deux postes
frontaliers reliant le kosovo avec la
servie en signe de protestation
plusieurs centaines de serbes du kosovo
bloquent une route menant à ces postes
les policiers font usage
de gaz lacrymogènes pour disperser la
foule pour le gouvernement kosovar cet
acte ne limite aucunement la liberté de
circulation entre le kosovo et la serbie
et surtout n'enfreint pas les droits de
la minorité serbe selon christina il
s'agit simplement d'une réponse à la
même pratique utilisée depuis longtemps
du côté serbe
ces plaques temporaires ne sont pas ceux
que nous souhaitons mais nous y sommes
forcés par l'autre côté cela fait dix
ans que nous conte citoyens payent de
telle plaque à l'entrée de la serbie en
serbie cet acte est vu comme une
violation flagrante de l'accord de libre
circulation signé initialement en 2011
puis réactualisé en 2016 le président
serbe s'adresse alors à la communauté
internationale en lui demandant d'
exercer son poids diplomatique afin
d'influencer la position des autorités
kosovares si cela ne fonctionne pas
belgrade promet une réponse douloureuse
a pris stinat évoque déjà des
conséquences possibles pour le dialogue
bilatéral
je ne vois pas le sens du dialogue en ce
moment et pourtant la médiation de
bruxelles a finalement permis de trouver
un compromis le 30 octobre le kosovo
consent à retirer ses forces spéciales
des deux postes frontaliers
simultanément les barricades érigées par
les serbes seront démantelées en outre
les conducteurs serbes et kosovars ne
seront plus obligés de démonter leurs
plaques mais seulement de recouvrir les
symboles de souveraineté à l'aide
d'autocollants l'accord définitif sur
les plaques et va faire l'objet de
négociations ultérieures entre les deux
parties pourra-t-il aboutir à une
solution durable sachant que les
tentatives précédentes de normaliser les
relations ont donné très peu de
résultats les accords conclus à
washington l'année dernière ont permis
un certain progrès dans le domaine
économique mais le règlement politique
reste dans l'impasse la médiation de
l'ue ne porte pas non plus beaucoup de
fruit de rencontres au plus haut niveau
ont été organisées en juin et en juillet
mais leur résultat s'avère quasi nulles
les parties s'accusent mutuellement de
tentatives de bloquer le dialogue c'est
un passé dieu largement à une vision
différente des objectifs des pourparlers
par exemple le premier ministre kosovar
albi courty cherche avant tout la
reconnaissance du kosovo côté serbe son
intransigeance sur ce dossier est
d'ailleurs l'une des raisons de l'échec
des récents pourparlers au plus haut
niveau selon la présidence serbe
de plus
le seul sujet était quand vous
reconnaîtrez l'indépendance du kosovo je
les ai écoutés attentivement pendant
quelques minutes et puis probablement
parce que je suis calme et je ne
réagissais pas curtis se tourna vers -
et répéta cinq fois quand caen caen
et puis je me suis retournée et donne
ton calme j'ai dit et bien jamais
pour la serbie l'un des objectifs clés
de ce dialogue est d'obtenir le feu vert
des autorités kosovares pour la création
de l'association des communes serbes en
organe locales représentant la minorité
serbe au kosovo actuellement les
communes à majorité serbe fonctionne en
vase clos et ont peu de contacts avec le
reste du pays selon un rapport du
département d'état américain publié
l'année dernière la population de ces
communes fait l'objet de discriminations
sociales notamment en matière d'emploi
le nombre d'incidents visant les serbes
restent élevés en sont dits volontaires
attaques physiques vols au niveau de la
représentation politique les serbes pèse
très peu le parti a appelé la liste
serbe pour le kosovo à seulement 10
sièges sur 120 au parlement kosovar et
un seul ministre dans le gouvernement
actuel alors quelles sont les
perspectives qui se dessinent pour le
dialogue entre la serbie et le kosovo
comment la serbie tantôt tel d'empêcher
la reconnaissance internationale du
kosovo où le dirigeant que ce marché
rechute il un soutien diplomatique
la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
après dix ans de tentatives de
réconciliation avec la médiation de l'ue
eux l'impasse est totale dans le
dialogue entre belgrade et pristina
alors que le dirigeant que sera rejette
l'idée d'une autonomie serbes au kosovo
belgrade ne veut même pas entendre
parler de l'indépendance de son ancienne
province qu'ils ne contrôlent plus
depuis plus d'une vingtaine d'années à
partir du début des années 1990 le
processus de l'éclatement de la
yougoslavie multiethnique abouti après
plusieurs conflits armés à la création
de plusieurs nouveaux états
en 1998 au kosovo province serbe à
majorité albanophone des affrontements
éclatent entre les indépendantistes
albanophones et les troupes serbes
accusant belgrade de répression contre
la population civile l'otan entament
sans l'accord du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu une campagne de bombardements
contre la yougoslavie en 1999 à la suite
de ces opérations une mission de l'onu
la minuk et chargé d'administrer
provisoirement la province est une force
de paix internationale
la kfor y est déployée en 2005 le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu donne le
feu vert pour les négociations sur le
statut final du kosovo
la médiation entre les deux parties est
assurée par l'envoyé spécial onusien
martti ahtisaari
en 2007 il préconise l'indépendance du
kosovo avec une période initiale sous
supervision internationale
le plan qu'il propose est favorablement
accueillie par cristina mais rejetée par
belgrade
de plus son approbation par le conseil
de sécurité de l'onu est bloquée par la
russie alliée de la serbie dès lors en
l'absence d'avancée dans les
négociations le parlement de pristina
proclame l'indépendance en février 2008
cette proclamation divise la communauté
internationale
certains pays notamment la russie et la
chine ou en europe l'espagne et chypre y
voit une violation du principe
d'intégrité territoriale des états
d'autres comme les états unis le royaume
uni
l'allemagne ou la france reconnaissent
immédiatement l'indépendance du kosovo
l'événement provoque une crise politique
en serbie où deux camps politiques se
forment les uns donnant la priorité à la
conservation de l'intégrité territoriale
de la serbie les autres sans y renoncer
formellement à l'adhésion à l'union
européenne
la coalition pro européenne du président
boris tadic remporte les élections et ce
dernier dépose officiellement la
candidature de la serbie pour adhérer à
l'union européenne en décembre 2009 à
partir de 2011 la serbie et le kosovo
entament des négociations sous les
auspices de l'union européenne afin de
régler des points techniques dans leur
relation en 2011 plusieurs accords sont
signés en particulier sur la libre
circulation des personnes puis des
marchandises en avril 2013 les deux
participent à bruxelles un accord
prévoyant l'octroi d'une certaine
autonomie locale aux municipalités
serbes du kosovo cet accord permet à la
serbie d'entamer au début de l'année
suivante les négociations d'adhésion à
l'union européenne
quant au kosovo il signe en 2015 un
accord de stabilisation et d'association
avec l'union européenne ce qui le met
sur la voie d'une intégration future
cependant ces progrès bute sur le refus
de la reconnaissance par belgrade de
l'indépendance de la république kosovars
conditions pour intégrer lieu de son
côté christine nagel en 2015 la mise en
oeuvre de l'accord sur les municipalités
serbes en 2020 l'administration trump
parvient à remettre les deux voisins
autour d'une table afin de négocier des
accords principalement économique
cependant ces accords peine à se
concrétiser
d'autant plus que le président kosovar
hashim thaçi est inculpé par le tribunal
spécial de la haye de crimes de guerre
et de crimes contre l'humanité lors de
la guerre de
1998-1999
de plus de nouvelles élections
législatives au kosovo en 2021 amène au
pouvoir albine curti nommé en mars
premier ministre d'emblée il adopte un
ton plus dur envers la serbie laissant
en suspens l'avenir du dialogue
bilatéral pour promouvoir sa cause le
kosovo ne cesse de développer ses
relations internationales quel est le
résultat de ces efforts aujourd'hui 98
pays membres de l'onu reconnaisse l'état
kosovar plus trois pays non membres ce
nombre aurait pu être de 116 mais une
quinzaine de pays ayant précédemment
reconnu le kosovo ont changé d'avis ces
dernières années parmi les pays de
l'otan 26 sur 30 reconnaisse le kosovo
et dans l'union européenne
ils sont 22 sur 27
les etats-unis eux sont les premiers à
reconnaître l'indépendance du kosovo en
washington continue depuis l'émergence
de sa souveraineté c'est tout d'abord
via une aide financière directe en 2020
à elle s'élève à presque 50 7 millions
de dollars une somme significative pour
le petit kosovo en plus les états unis
soutiennent la transformation des forces
de sécurité du kosovo en une vraie armée
ils fournissent de l'armement à pristina
temps sous contrat que sous forme de
cadeaux d'autre part washington
s'implique de plus en plus dans le
kosovo dans le cadre de l'otan en mai
dernier pour la première fois pris
stinat accueille des manoeuvres de
l'alliance sur son territoire un appui
qui n'est d'ailleurs pas complètement
altruiste car le kosovo accueille la
plus grande base américaine dans
l'europe du sud-est le camp bondsteel
établi en juin 1999 est toujours active
elle peut accueillir jusqu'à 7000
militaires la diplomatie kosovare peut
aussi se vanter de quelques succès
marqué à l'aide de son allié américain
grâce aux efforts de washington le
kosovo vient d'obtenir une
reconnaissance de plus c'est celle
d'israël le 1er février dernier près
stinat et tel aviv établissent des
relations diplomatiques mutuel lors
d'une réunion en ligne en quête de
reconnaissance le kosovo ouvre en mars
une ambassade jerusalem une première
pour un pays majoritairement musulman un
pas qui s'avère coûteux pour les deux
parties pour israël le prix et la
bienveillance de la serbie en septembre
dernier à belgrade se dit prêt à
déplacer son ambassade à jérusalem mais
après la reconnaissance israël est du
kosovo les plans sont mises à l'arrêt
christina elle reçoit des critiques de
la part de l'union européenne et
pourrait même perdre une dizaine de
reconnaissance de pays mécontent de son
rapprochement avec l'état hébreu selon
les informations des médias serbes
pourtant le kosovo n'en démord pas dans
sa quête de reconnaissance universelle
il peut compter non seulement sur
washington mais aussi sur la turquie
c'est ce qu'a confirmé récemment le
président r douanes
vous savez qu'il existe des états a
servi et le kosovo ont fait partie nous
sommes là pour aider nous essayons de
vrais à accroître le nombre de pays qui
reconnaissent son indépendance une
déclaration aussitôt critiquée en serbie
la turquie est une grande puissance
erdogan est grand je suis petit
insignifiant mais la serbie n'est pas si
petit que cela pour qu elle n'essaye pas
de résister en effet belgrade mène
depuis plusieurs années une campagne
diplomatique contre la reconnaissance du
kosovo surtout pour le priver des
reconnaissances déjà existantes pour y
arriver la serbie us de plusieurs
méthodes depuis les simples visites
diplomatiques jusqu'au avantages
accordés aux pays cibles ainsi belgrade
aboli le régime de visas pour le surinam
le burundi la dominique et palau ou
encore conclu un accord de coopération
agricole avec le lesotho élire et
parfois jusqu'à offrir des paiements
pour la révocation de la reconnaissance
du kosovo c'est ce qu'a rapporté la
presse africaine en 2019 concernant la
centrafrique tous ces pays avaient
établi auparavant des relations avec le
kosovo mais on fait marche arrière ses
dernières années au total 15 pays ont
renoncé à leur reconnaissance de
pristina voire 18 selon belgrade la
serbie est aussi préoccupé par les
tentatives du kosovo de se faire
admettre dans plusieurs organisations
internationales depuis le nu jusqu'au
conseil de l'europe or belgrade résiste
avec succès à ses avances et kosovars
surtout grâce à l'aide de deux alliés
puissants la russie et la chine les deux
appuie la position serbe sur le kosovo
dans le processus de règlement tout
comme sur la scène internationale moscou
et pékin sont membres du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu et ont du coup le
droit de veto sur toute demande du
kosovo à rejoindre les nations unies la
russie et la chine mène aussi une
résistance à l'adhésion du kosovo dans
d'autres organisations internationales
en 2015 par exemple christina voit sa
demande d'adhésion à l'unesco rejeter
n'ayant pas pu recueillir les deux tiers
des votes nécessaires et en 2018 et 2019
le kosovo retire sa demande de rejoindre
interpol faute de soutien en septembre
2020 l'accord de washington mais à un
moratoire sur toute tentative kosovars
d'adhérer à des organes internationaux
pourtant il prend fin en septembre 2021
ce qui inquiète belgrade
ils vont essayer de devenir membre du
conseil de l'europe et nous aurons un
soutien massif des pays européens après
cela et tenteront d'entrer à interpol et
à l'unesco pour y voir plus clair nous
revenons vers alexis troude professeur
de géopolitique à l'université de melin
directeur de l'institut europe orientale
monsieur troude le kosovo est un membre
de l'union européenne et de le temps
c'est pour bientôt selon vous alors
effectivement le qu'aux avec tous les
autres pays des balkans occidentaux fait
partie des derniers pays à rentrer dans
l'union européenne et dans l'otan je
rappelle aux auditeurs que ces fameux
balkans occidentaux l'ancienne
yougoslavie
forment un véritable trou noir en europe
puisque quand on regarde la carte de
l'europe c'est la dernière région
d'europe qui n'est pas dans l'union
européenne
alors le dernier pays de rentrer dans
l'union européenne et en croatie et dans
l'otan le monténégro et
donc le kosovo dans ce contexte là
feraient partie d'un si oui d'un
troisième wagon parce que d'un côté le
kosovo pour les dirigeants européenne et
l'otan rentrer dans ces deux
institutions avec a servi donc à mon
avis à partir de 2028 mais à une
condition c'est que ces négociations
dont on parlait tout à l'heure et bien
réussissent et donc je ne suis pas sûr
que d'ici 2028 2030
le kosovo rentrer dans ces institutions
pour la simple et bonne raison que son
avenir dépend de l'avenir surtout de la
serbie est et queens de la serbie
doit-elle abandonner sa lutte pour le
kosovo qui freine son intégration
européenne non la serbie ne doit surtout
pas abandonner sa politique de non
reconnaissance du kosovo à l'heure
actuelle
vous savez qu'il faut deux tiers des
voix de l'onu pour qu'un pays soit man
devenu or on en est loin pour que ce mot
puisque kosovo est reconnue que par 92
pays sur
213 ce qui est peu et surtout ce que nos
auditeurs de savoir c'est que ces
dernières années la serbie a mené une
très belle 10.6 qui l'amenait à
faire revenir en arrière
sur leur décision 16 pays 16 pays sur
213 qui au départ en 2008 2009 avait
accordé l'indépendance au kosovo et qui
sont venus sur la décision parce que les
diplomates serbe lors expliquer ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure c'est à dire le
fait qu'il soit un état failli et un
état qui forme qui est le réceptacle de
toutes les tous les trafics en europe et
donc l'avenir de la serbie lui se place
sous des auspices quand même assez
positif puisque la serbie n'a pas que
l'union européenne et l'otan pourra
venir la serbie a même une très belle
géopolitique avec des grandes puissances
asiatiques tels que la russie la chine
la turquie la serbie a des relations
très fortes avec la russie pas tant
parce que il y à une pseudo et ça c'est
excusable en tout cas une amitié
historique avec la russie et surtout
parce que elle a des liens très forts
avec l'économie russe et les rues
s'investissent énormément serbie dans
des façons la chine est très bien
implanté en serbie la chine qui a
développé un secteur énergétique les
transports en serbie et même la turquie
pardon la tweetie la turquie devient un
acteur très important
en service
si on regarde encore plus largement même
si la serbie ne veut pas choisir entre
l'est et l'ouest elle peut très bien
rentrer dans ce qu'on appelle le groupe
de visegrad
c'est à dire ce groupe formé des pays
d'europe centrale qui sont finalement et
dans l'union européenne et aux marges
des européennes mais qui sont en train
de construire quand même
des solutions politiques assez
intéressante
le président wu chih tx a même proposé
dernièrement avec le président de bosnie
le président de turquie un mini schengen
bon vous voyez rien n'est décidé et dans
un bois proche on verra la serbie
vraiment trouvé sa place dans cette
dans ce jeu s'ils voulaient de balance
entre l'est et l'ouest merci beaucoup
monsieur tron pour cet éclairage je
rappelle alexis trou du professeur de
géopolitique à l'université de melun un
directeur de l'institut europe orientale
et est aujourd'hui avec nous merci
encore cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial à
bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]